do you know who's the third largest
semiconductor company in the world the
first two are relatively easy to guess
they're nvidia and tsmc but what about
the third one some good guesses would be
intel qualcomm and ti but the answer is
actually a company called asml currently
asml boasts a market cap of just under
300 billion dollars coming in at the
29th largest publicly traded company in
the world to put that in perspective
their market cap is currently over twice
that of amd aside from a behemoth market
cap in terms of semiconductor wait for
front-end equipment market share asml
was the second largest single market
shareholder coming in at 15.4 percent
only beaten up by applied materials yet
most people have never even heard about
asml so here's the story of asml and how
they became the 300 billion shadow chip
company
taking a look back the story of asml
dates back to the netherlands to the
year 1984. at that time many chip
companies were trying to commercialize a
manufacturing technique called
photolithography photolithography is the
process of using light in order to
produce a thin protective film in terms
of semiconductors the thin film is
generally used to protect select
portions of silicon wafers this
technique actually has roots that date
back as far as 1820 to a french inventor
named nice for knives but it wasn't till
the 1970s that semiconductor companies
really started to leverage this process
in the meantime two relatively small
companies named royal philips
electronics and advanced semiconductor
materials international or asmi felt
that they were being left behind with
this process so they decided to make a
joint venture called advanced
semiconductor materials lithography or
asml despite being founded by two
existing companies the early days of
asml weren't glamorous by any means
phillips cleaned out a shed behind one
of their offices and that became the new
headquarters of asml over the next
several months asmr focused on
developing and integrating
photolithography and given that they
weren't inventing a new process from
scratch or anything it didn't take them
too long to come out with their first
system called the pas 2000 stepper if
you've ever wondered what the big
machines and chip factories are well
this is one of them anyway with their
first product up and running the parent
companies decided to up their
investments into asml by 1985 asml
upgraded to a newly built office and
factory located in beldhoven their
employee account also grew to a solid
100 employees soon after asml came out
with their second product in 1986 which
was the pas 2500 stepper as asmr's
product lineup grew they started to form
partnerships with established companies
such as the lens manufacturer carl zeiss
phillips also helped asml open locations
in taiwan and the united states but all
was not good here's the thing while asml
was churning out great products it was
nothing particularly new or innovative
there were already plenty of comparable
solutions from established semiconductor
companies and customers saw no reason to
take a gamble with the startup so asml
had high expenses and a little revenue
to make things worse one of the parent
companies asmi would call it quits in
the mid-1980s they sold their 50-person
stake in sml to phillips and left the
startup while philips purchased the
stake from asmi they weren't optimistic
about asml either philips investors were
starting to suggest that asml was a lost
cause and that phillips should cut
losses as soon as possible considering
the dire situation asmos executives
reached out to phil's board member hank
bott and they were able to come to one
final deal
phillips would back one more round of
funding but if that didn't work or
wasn't enough they were going to shut
down asml
oftentimes it's when the sticks are the
highest that would produce the best
results and this couldn't be truer for
asml as they came out with a
breakthrough platform called the pas
5500.
the pas 5500 boasted industry-leading
productivity and resolution which
motivated many customers to give the
startup a shot and this is exactly what
asml needed to finally return a profit
despite the positive progress though
phillips was still looking to get out of
asml
so in 1995 they took asmr public on the
amsterdam and new york stock exchanges
at roughly a billion valuation phillips
sold half of their stake at ipl and they
slowly sold off the rest of their stock
over the next couple of years and with
that philips was completely out of the
business but that was okay as they had
already done their part in keeping asml
alive ever since then sml has expanded
into three other categories aside from
lithography which include the track
division the thermal division and the
special applications division starting
with the track division this part of the
company focuses on producing equipment
that can coat develop and bake
light-sensitive materials onto a wafer
surface moving on to the thermal
division this sector produces furnaces
and deposition systems the furnaces are
used to heat up wafers during the
manufacturing process and the deposition
systems are used to remove chemical
vapors and finally the special
applications division is basically just
a customization department this sector
customizes products produced by the
other departments to meet customer needs
for example one customer might need
larger furnaces in order to manufacture
larger batches of wafers similarly
another customer might need smaller
furnaces and so on and so forth looking
at these divisions you probably realize
that asml isn't actually a chip
manufacturer themselves instead they
primarily deal with manufacturing
producing equipment so they're basically
the top of the semiconductor food chain
when you buy an iphone apple turns
around and gets foxconn to manufacture
the smartphone foxconn then turns around
and calls up tsmc to source the chips
and then tsmc turns around and calls up
asml to get their equipment so though
asml is mostly invisible to the public
without them basically nothing would
take place anyway going back to the late
1990s the dot-com bubble wasn't full
force and asml leveraged the bubble to
raise money and continue innovation they
were no longer innovating to catch up
though they were innovating to lead the
market in 1996 asml introduced their
step and scan system which blew away the
competition this system was capable of
producing 100 wafers per hour which was
nearly double the standard 60 wafers per
hour seeing this the us department of
energy invited asml to expand its
presence in the u.s through the xtreme
ultraviolet llc program as the name
suggests the program aimed to upgrade
traditional photo lithography to use
extreme ultraviolet light asml did
eventually end up figuring out this
technology and customers far preferred
it anyway by the end of the century asmr
grew to be the second largest
semiconductor supplier in the world
unfortunately though this was the
highest point they would see for a
decade
by now we've discussed the dot-com crash
so many times on this channel that i'm
sure you guys know what went down years
of exuberance speculation and opium
finally came crashing down in the early
2000s which crushed the entire stock
market and especially tech companies and
asml was by no means immune to this asml
was expecting a slowdown as the chip
industry often operates in boom and bust
cycles but the bust was far worse than
they anticipated asml had to other
investors the 2001 sales should be
roughly the same as 2 000. so they were
tempering expectations but by march of
2001 it became clear that even matching
sales was going to be impossible asmr
froze hiring and focused on just
completing existing contracts but
companies were pulling out of contracts
left and right for example intel
canceled a 100 million order by the end
of 2001 net sales had nearly half in
comparison to 2000 from 3.1 billion
euros to 1.84 billion euros asml also
put in a painful
422.4 million loss and as you would
guess their stock graph didn't look much
better by october of 2002 asmr stock was
down a full 90 from their peak in 2000
despite the harsh decline asml actually
fared a lot better than the rest of the
industry given that asml did eventually
recover and put in new all-time highs
but back in the early 2000s things were
only getting worse for asml at the end
of 2001 nikon filed a patent
infringement lawsuit against asml nikon
claimed that asml had imprinted upon
seven of their pants leading to
microlithography equipment a couple of
months later in april of 2002 asmr
countersuited nikon suggesting that it
was nikon that infringed upon asml's
patents this didn't work out too well
for asml though as the two eventually
came to a settlement where asml paid
nikon 87 billion dollars fortunately
though things finally started turn
around for asml after the lawsuit asml
had started shipping out their twin scan
systems which offered a revolutionary
dual stage technology instead of
measuring and aligning a wafer and then
exposing it twin scan systems could do
both tasks simultaneously this
technology allowed customers to produce
smaller chips faster and more
efficiently than ever before also do you
remember the extreme ultraviolet
technology or the euv technology that
asmr started working on in the late
1990s well they shipped their first euv
lithography machine called the nxt 3100
in 2010 and they've been a leader in uv
lithography ever since aside from
rolling out new technologies asmr was
slowly acquiring companies in the
background for example in 2001 they
acquired silicon valley group for 1.6
billion dollars similarly in 2007 they
acquired brian technologies for 270
million dollars and in 2013 they
acquired cyber for 2.5 billion dollars
all these acquisitions allowed asmr to
return to the dot com peak by mid 2013
but asml was just getting started
over the past five to seven years asml
has been doing better than ever before
because the semiconductor industry has
been doing better than ever before due
to three main reasons starting with amd
in 2017 amd introduced the ryzen liner
processors which made gaming computers
more affordable and powerful than ever
before this led to more casual gamers
entering the pc master race which
substantially increased demand for cpus
and the gpus around the same time
bitcoin was making its first move
towards the moon rising to 20 thousand
dollars by this point it already didn't
make sense to use gpus to mine bitcoin
but it did make sense to use gpus to
mine ethereum and given how profitable
theory mining was miners basically
bought up the entire gpu market and
seeing how much demand there was for
gpus nvidia decided to significantly
hike prices with the launch of the 2000
series and these prices have never gone
down and finally to make things even
worse the pandemic brought what did the
supply shortage which has just made it
even easier for suppliers to hike prices
and increase profit margins considering
the semiconductor boom i don't think
you'd be too surprised here that sms
revenues and profits have grown several
fold in the mid 2010s sml was pulling in
six to seven billion revenue every year
in the most recent 12 month period
however they pulled in over 20 billion
dollars similarly in the mid-2010s sml
was pulling in about 1.5 billion dollars
in that profit every year in the most
recent 12-month period however asmr
pulled in 6.4 billion net profit so
things are going quite well for asml
right now but as we saw in 2000 it
doesn't take that long for things to
turn around the supply shortage is not
going to last forever cryptocurrencies
are moving towards proof-of-stake which
eliminates a need for gpus and asics and
it's just a matter of time until the new
influx of gamers due to rise and start
to stagnate so the next decline is just
a matter of when not if but regardless
of when that decline comes around it's
clear that asml isn't going anywhere
anytime soon and for all of our sakes
that's probably a good thing were you
guys familiar with asml comment that
down below also drop a like if you're
thankful for asml and of course consider
checking out our international channels
to watch our videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you